let's get the latest on the war in
Ukraine joining us is military analyst
Philip Ingram good to see you now we
were talking an hour ago and immediately
after you went got this news in from the
Russian defense Ministry talking about
some kind of airstrike
which has killed hundreds of Ukrainian
troops what more do we know well this is
what the Russian Minister of Defense saw
as I refer to it as the ministry of
disinformation
um has said on day 319 of Vladimir
Putin's 10-day military operation
they're claiming an attack that they've
identified over the last 24 hours
Ukrainian troop concentrations in a
building in the town of chromatorsk that
we can see in the center there and that
they attacked it with rockets
um have killed over 600. no that's
interesting they've said it's in
retaliation to the Ukrainian New Year's
Eve strike in the city of McKeever that
the ukrainians claimed that they killed
400 Russians in and the Russians said
that they had lost 89 in that
um it's interesting the Ukrainian
commentary channels are ridiculing this
report out of the Russian Minister of
Defense there are pictures that the
minister of defense or their propaganda
channels are putting up but those are
unverified at the moment I take it with
a pinch of salt what else is happening
then back moots and zaparesia key focus
at the moment yeah but backward we've
been talking about this for months we've
got the ukrainians actually fixing the
Russians in the backwood area the
Russians are trying to encircle the city
to then capture it there was some talk
of them capturing the salt mines
um in just to the north of it but the
ukrainians will continue to hold the
Russians there whilst the ukrainians are
probing into cremina trying to look at
counter-attacking into that ground line
of communication we can see going
through criminal down to the um the east
of bakmut and further down to Donetsk
um the last few weeks ago the Russians
put additional defenses approximately on
the line that we can see there are the
yellow line but the the ukrainians could
use that as an access to
counter-attacking and then last night we
had UK Ministry of Defense talking of a
defensive line between the vasilifka and
orchive area increasing the defenses
along there because they're potentially
expecting a Ukrainian Contra attack done
in through that zaparisha bit that would
be significant because that would split
that land bridge from Crimea up to
Russia that
um everyone's been focusing on here so
either of those are bad options for
Russia should the ukrainians counter
attack and suggestions of further
Russian troops going into Belarus
there are there's also been some talk of
shelling overnight into again this is
Russian Russian information saying that
they've attacked the the two power
plants that we can see here but this has
been unconfirmed it's interesting the
Russians have been attacking Ukrainian
power plants
um trying to break the will of the
Ukrainian people over recent months but
they're now saying ukrainians are
shelling into Russian controlled power
plants what Belarus as you say the
Russians are putting an awful lot more
troops and Equipment into Belarus it's
and they're putting some good equipment
in there as well and they've been using
it as a training ground for the
reservists that they called up
um it's not clear whether what they're
doing is preparing an Attack Force to
try and attack down into Kiev again at
some stage and split the Ukrainian
defenses Ukrainian defenses will have to
be split anyway to prepare for that just
in case
um or whether this is just some big
Bluff that will come out over the coming
weeks